is
[Music]
the o
he
[Music]
oh
the
[Music]
o
got
[Music]
you
this
[Music]
o
the
[Music]
15 minutes in 90 minutes remain no
solves
yet all prizes remain up for grab AB s
[Music]
the
o
oh
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
o
o the
[Music]
you
he
[Music]
la
o
got
[Music]
he
the
[Music]
o
is
[Music]
he
all right we have our first solve here
at minute
76 dust 2 dust 2 where are
you congratulations on getting this
started kicked off here in the finals
you've got the lead how does it feel
a little bit nervous actually a little
bit nervous what is your hacking spirit
animal that you try to uh inhabit while
you
hack
sorry all right we'll go with the
elephant they're very
[Music]
o
second so NP hard we've got two people
up on the leaderboard to take the top
two spots so far with 72 minutes left NP
hard where are you remind me all right
good
work what did you eat for breakfast
that's making you so successful
today power of Corgi all right love it
power of Corgi and the shirt says it
all let's see you can jump into the
number three spot I'm betting it's
happening soon and then it's going to be
a Race So you could finish the next two
challenges
[Music]
pap
the
o
[Music]
e
o
the
[Music]
in the leaderboard third solve looks
like they went with a different
challenge to start so one now in first
place currently poised for $110,000
rewards we've
got DS 2 in second place currently
poised for 7500 in rewards and NP hard
for
5,000 in rewards uh currently as it
stands where is one
located top of the leaderboard where are
you that
you all right they're staying it on I
okay fair
enough 65 minutes remain and remember if
we have three people solve all three
that'll end the clock before the
remaining 64 minutes so keep hacking
away guys
[Music]
the
o
[Music]
oh e
pap
[Music]
the
1 hour remaining 1 hour remaining
[Music]
the
o
[Music]
la
the
[Music]
got a real race for the prizes now rage
congrats for getting on the board got
three folks who have solved one
particular Challenge and then one at the
top of the leaderboard who solved a
different challenge so wide open for
who's going to get the rewards but again
as it stands now we've got one taking
home
$110,000 in addition to their winnings
already
7500 for dust 2 and NP hard uh would get
$5,000 in this round so anybody's game
still 51 minutes and 45 seconds left
keep hustling everybody's doing a great
job
the
[Music]
another update to the leaderboard
one pushing ahead by solving the Second
Challenge so on their way it's possibly
capturing the
$10,000 Grand price
eyes reminder that places 4 through 14
in the finals all receive the same
amount so if we have a top three that
solve all three before the timers up the
finals will be over so
he
[Music]
the
welcome to the leaderboard Mage
inter it's heating up who can get into
those top three spots for the big prize
money 47 minutes to go
you
[Music]
Bill joins the leaderboard in position
two to shake things up a bit in the top
three MP hard drops to number four so
good work Bill getting in there for the
$7500 spot as of right now
o
[Music]
this
the
[Music]
w
welcome to the leaderboard
slipper slipper with two solves very
quickly to put them into second place
now over
bill so it's heating up we've got two
folks with two solves the first one to
get the last one is going to take home
the $10,000 prize unless someone can
solve two before they get to that last
one with third place wide open still but
being held by Bill as we
speak just under 40 minutes left of the
final round round coming into it before
in case it ends as people start to solve
things want to give a big thank you to
the ethereum foundation I want to give a
huge thank you to our friends here at
Friendly malti citizens putting together
these awesome
challenges we appreciate all the hard
work you did on that and then we also
want to give a huge shout out to uh the
upcoming ethereum protocol attack ofon
with rewards up to 1.5 million and the
wonderful support uh that we've all
received from biit Wormhole arbitrum
great events so keep it up everyone keep
your heads down coming in the home
stretch here
[Music]
the
o
[Music]
oh
back e
[Music]
the
got e
[Music]
30 minutes remaining 30 minutes
remaining
[Music]
the oh
la
com
[Music]
he
e
[Music]
the only change to the leader
leaderboard we have is Bill getting a
second solve a few minutes ago that
means that our one two and three right
now are all racing to get that third
solve first one to do it gets the
$10,000 grand
prize coming down to the wire we got 22
minutes left three people in the
driver's seat to stay in one two and
three and plenty others behind who can
certainly get up there as well so keep
it up let's see what happens
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
the
o
to e
[Music]
w
la
the
to
[Music]
all right players we have 15 minutes
left and as a token of my appreciation
for letting me bother you all day while
you're trying to focus we will release a
hint right now to see who could try to
take home the prize in the last 15
minutes
is
[Music]
there were typos on the first hint so
there's a second hint out there now to
clarify
the
[Music]
as it stands now we still have one in
first place with $10,000 prize as it
stands now 7500 to slipper if if things
stand as they are and Bill would take
home 5,000 the rest of the pool up to
the to the rest
however it does seem that if there's one
solution to one of these uh to one of
the ones that has not been solved yet
that person can easily jump into first
place if there's no other solvers so
anybody's game in this room in the last
12 minutes good luck
you
[Music]
the
it's 10 minutes
to
[Music]
you
the
[Music]
under
oh
[Music]
this
five minutes remaining but we can now
say with confidence that slipper is the
inaugural
champion of the Devcon CTF and will take
home the grand prize of
$10,000 in addition to what he's already
made today so 10,000 plus what he's
already made and the physical gift will
be giving him huge hand for his work
today there's still a few minutes left
to see who can take the other uh spots
cuz it's wide open with uh with one more
solve for for pretty much anyone on the
board right now
[Music]
the
oh e
[Music]
5 seconds will anybody be able to
everyone in this room should be pretty
proud that was a lot of people that came
in this room and did some speed hacking
today and today uh a huge congrats to uh
slipper where are you
slipper come on up for a
minute congratulations on winning the
whole thing I have a question for you
you took a little bit of a mitigated
risk there in holding two answers at the
same time it looked like you submitted
them back to back was that intentional
strategy to put pressure on one uh so I
saw I have already submitted the one
solution but it turns out I was not
showed on the scoreboard so I just
realized I didn't submit the one
successfully so
so it looked like a brilliant strategy
that was actually a brilliant accident
um congratulations you did a fantastic
job today uh how do you think you'll
spend the
money uh how much would I
get 5,000 cuz you and I all split $5,000
no $110,000 plus what you already got uh
from the previous round so you'll get a
little over $10,000 and a gift from us
at the award ceremony later but
I haven't decided yet so but I would
thank uh chat gbt for helping me so I
would pay for them so a nice donation to
go to chat GPT for uh for helping during
the competition congratulations to you
for being the inaugural winner I want to
uh I want to shout out really quickly
again um our great friends over here the
friendly malti citizens for putting
these challenges together I think they
did a really great job of putting
challenges that were uh difficulty type
and managing the event and the platform
so we really appreciate their help here
um our team here as well I want to thank
the ethereum foundation for allowing us
to run this the first one they've done I
believe at Devcon and hopefully not the
last um and for being our partner in
doing so and I really want to thank the
um as you know the upcoming
attakathi to get you up to speed um and
the sponsors of that program who are
supporting it huge round of applause I
also want to uh I want to congratulate
our second and third place uh winners
for $5,000 so that's one where's One
raise your hand one stand up one one
stand up
[Applause]
one and then Bill where's Bill plus what
you did earlier today so um really great
work by all of you I think you're all
coming out in the in the black today by
getting getting some rewards in cash we
also have a reward for you later which
we'll do at the you know uh award
ceremony here after we do a little bit
of a fireside chat um regarding security
so hopefully you'll stick around for
that so you can collect your gear and
then get to our team uh with uh your
your wallet numbers if you haven't
already done that so you can collect
your usdc in the next few weeks the last
thing is a lot of the folks in this room
which is amazing didn't even sign up
until they walked up today and just came
in and and uh dominated so really great
job on you all for showing up um coming
through here getting into the finals
making a few dollars uh and because of
that I don't believe you got swag packs
so we have swag packs for you as well
Ash if you could raise your hand over
there he has them for you so make sure
you collect those as well uh before you
before you deating um find anyone in
immuni shirt to give some feedback to
because we want to make sure we give
feedback to the ethereum foundation so
when they run the fireside chat
[Applause]
the
[Music]
oh
com
n
[Music]
this
la
[Music]
o
fire side chat here in about 3 minutes
[Music]
folks e
this
[Music]
o
all
to
[Music]
you
he
[Music]
all right folks we're going to get
started here in a minute if
[Music]
pap
finalists who just
participated quick reminder it's all
finalists who just participated please
stay here for the award ceremony so we
can give you your gift and ensure that
you've talked to our team and giving us
your wallet address so we could deliver
your reward money
all right with that I think we'll start
to get the fireside chat here going uh
since we got the live stream um and what
I think we'll do first to make it quite
easy on ourselves is just uh introduce
who we have here um you've heard me
talking all day so enough of me but I'm
mik o'keef I head up sales and customer
success at immuni um which is crowd
crowd secc uh bug Bounty programs and
audit competitions and I will let's just
move left to right to start
all right hey everyone my name is
Michael lellan I'm the head of solutions
architecture at open Zeppelin uh I focus
a lot on working with our security audit
team with some of our top clients
working on kind of weird uh out of
theordinary sort of audit requests maybe
things that are outside the evm um and
then also do a lot of work on security
operations for Dows security councils
and lots of other very particular thing
for the
industry hello uh my name is Neville so
I'm a a program analysis expert
primarily at um Management in doob um so
I'm also a co-founder my time is spread
throughout you know like Engineering
Management uh sales and a lot of
operations as a co-founder uh but yeah
hey I'm co-founder and CEO of zelic um
yeah my background is in vulnerability
research reverse engineering so I used
to do like iOS uh zero click is I mainly
just do zic with my Jazzy uh we recently
acquired a company called codeina you
might have heard of it um I work very
closely with that team as well now um so
that's kind of what I do
yeah I'm Petro I'm a lead auditor at
chain security and we are an auditing
company based in syc who's in U complex
defi projects and we've audited a bunch
of um uh project that you might know
maker curve uh Lio poly market we've got
bugs if you want
later uh we find them and we package
them
um and uh we specialize on evm
ecosystem awesome and so um thank you
all for joining the panel thanks for
coming here today uh nice way to end the
the long uh day of deep focus these
these folks had and I think it's been
great because I think immuni has worked
with all of you in different capacities
throughout the years so um it's it's a
great collection of folks here I'm going
to start with one that's a little off
script that that we hadn't talked about
yet is uh um Petro Petra you
participated today what did you think of
the CTF what did you think of the uh you
know how how you felt you performed yeah
so I'm not too satisfied with how I
performed i r very rarely interact with
rpcs myself so uh I found the bug quite
quite rapidly I was in round three and I
I think they were very easy to to spot
with uh with the onchain part
uh it was an interesting challenge still
and challenges and the the finals also
seemed very interesting but I haven't
read the code so I'm curious to see that
perhaps a team format would work uh
would work better for you next time you
spot the bugs and then you hand it off
to a to a teammate um yeah probably or
just uh taking a couple of hours to get
used to deploying stuff beforehand also
would have worked well we were thrilled
to have you participate um a lot of the
audience today a lot of the participants
in the CTF today which was fantastic uh
were developers security researchers
Auditors we had a really great mix and
many others I'm sure as well um so I
think keeping that in mind keeping the
audience in mind when we go through the
next few questions over the next 15
minutes or so um we can kind of cater to
those audiences however you please and
whatever angle you guys want want to
come at it from but the first thing I'd
like to ask is a lot of these folks are
involved in crowd sex security that's
kind of what the um you know what the uh
ethereum protocol attack ofon will be
about I'm curious how you all see crowd
secc um
security next to your businesses and how
you operate and maybe um and maybe where
I'll start actually is with you Luna
because you all recently acquired codina
um so you obviously see some value the
audit so I'd love to hear your
perspective yeah I mean the main reason
we carded code arena is we just think we
can deliver like better experience
better security for our customers the
main thing that I I would show is this
concept that we have introduced called
audits plus so when you have a
consultative audit you're going to get
like you know a small number of very
highly skilled people and they're going
to look at the most important parts of
the protocol but it's fundamentally a
timeboxed audit right so they're going
to get maybe one week two week three
weeks to look at this thing so they
can't afford to look at every single
like gas optimization that there could
be or like oh no this function is not
documented they need to go find and make
sure that the critical variants of the
protocol are firm now on the other hand
a lot of times you do want to get
information about all the possible
things that could go wrong and not just
that you may want to have you know
hundreds or thousands of eyes on the
code base because that is what you want
before you uh not just you know ship it
to mainnet but also before you put it in
front of a bug Bounty right because that
would be very expensive the earlier you
catch a bug in your Dev integration test
or the unit test or the code review
internal audit the earlier catch these
things it's cheaper so you want to you
know get a consultative audit because
you can have a firm Authority say like
okay yeah we looked at it and we're
pretty sure it's secure um and then you
want the additional reassurance of like
okay now not just that we've got a crowd
of people that looked at it and it's
definitely been very thoroughly picked
apart so because of that we think that
consultative Audits and competitive
audits um or you know crowd security
these two go hand inand in creating
something that's extremely uh High
Assurance so that's kind of what we
think we think that crowd security is
very important yeah that's I mean why we
CED Crow Arena wonderful I'll open up to
the rest of the panel for anyone that's
got a response to this question as
well uh well crowds um this kind of
security is really really effective and
it's really enabled by the community I
mean listen um everyone is motivated to
learn new technologies bounties um which
is the line last line of defense I mean
be having participated in bug bounties
myself you know I feel that you are
highly motivated you know like to spend
a whole night looking for a bug or
something like that um so yeah it is
highly effective you know in certain
contexts but it really depends who's
there you know looking at myself
predeployment post- deployment yeah um
it's a model we definitely seen a lot of
our clients start to work with like we
do mainly con consultative audit te um
we expect to continue to do it we expect
to continue to see demand but um we've
definitely seen a lot of clients that
are like specifically integrating us
into a broader process where you know
we're typically doing a private audit or
consultative audit um and then they plan
to later go to a uh a crowdsource
competition so it's it's good from the
perspective if like if we did buy some
chance which is always some chance miss
something like there is additional uh
layers of security that are going to
potentially catch that so it's not all
on us um you know and potentially
there's several private audits as well
um and then afterwards we've actually
found ourselves working more and more
with clients in the fix review process
of competitive audits because of the
fact that uh you can have a lot of
issues coming in um even if they're low
that could be uh applied to the code
base and having someone who's already
seen that code base and picked it apart
a bit uh can help with the fix review
process as well and ensure it uh the
code is as secure as possible before it
goes to main net so um yeah I do expect
this is going to be a model that
continues to grow and there's going to
be probably a lot of coordination
between both private and competitive
Audits and the ways that clients use
them yeah so we work with u traditional
audits but we we also uh recommend a
competitive audit if you can also afford
it and uh we have seen between the two
uh competitive audits don't guarantee
that you will have good people but in
generally you have a high probability
that people who are skilled at what
you're doing will look at it and they
will find specific things in which they
are very proficient uh what we do is
really more trying to cover everything
and um we try to give guarantees uh in
the sense that we we know what we
understand and we know what we don't
understand at the end of an audit with a
competitive audit it's harder to uh to
know what's been seen and what's not
been
scen yeah um and one thing we really
like about like the collaboration
between uh close collaboration between
an audit firm like a open Zeppelin chain
security or zelic for example um and a
competitive audit is that for example
you do the private audit and then the
researchers who were assigned on that
private audit now they have a very high
context understanding of the codebase
and they can prepare the notes that then
arm the or equip the community Auditors
to be even more effective than they
would if they had just been going in
blind so to speak they can be like hey
watch out for these parts um these parts
are especially important to check but of
course don't let that rabbit hole you
one more thing I to add is uh if you
start with a private audit first you're
more likely to be told you're not ready
go back and try again uh as opposed to a
Cod competition that's just going to say
all right it's payday so probably do the
private art first 400 issues
so
true excellent point um so I'll skip
around a little that you wish were more
widely adopted and why do you think they
may not be widely adopted
so I think developers uh often think
about security and they're not thinking
about uh their code in an adversarial
way from the get-go they should do more
should do more
uh code reviews internals they should do
more internal audits in a way where some
part of the team tries to break the
protocol uh I 100% code coverage uh I
know you guys out there you guys do not
have I think they're totally right you
should do functional requirements um and
then checks and variance and then you
know CFM just assert the constant
function is still constant at the end um
or like you know like the whatever
solvent that kind of thing if you just
throw a bunch of assertions at the end
it can just kill a lot of a lot of
attacks or at least mitigate them what
might have been a crit might now be a
medium yeah so one other thing that I
wish people do a bit more is uh more
static analysis and more formal
verification uh we don't see this as
much um probably because it's like a
little money for R&D at this point and
also like the underlying language
changes so much so it's hard to make
them really really spot on um but yeah
it might also be a cultural thing and
it's also like U this is like offloaded
to towards the Auditors so the Auditors
do use these tools but like the
developers themselves don't use them as
much
currently yeah production like
monitoring and looking for like it was
basically going to wreck them and they
actually were arguing with us saying
like oh it's not in the code I'm like
well now it's in the docs that was in
the code that was in the scope and it
would have wrecked your protocol uh so
we're going to count it um so I think
like people including the deployment
process is almost part of the code and
script uh to handle that process and
yeah never putting yourself in a
position where some EA key on some
developers laptop is hopefully not going
to get fished and wreck the protocol and
I wanted to add on to what Petro had to
say like it is true I think all of us
will empathize with the fact that a lot
of teams essentially this is very common
and I totally understand why they feel
that way because they just need to you
know go to market um they think of
security in like a oh we'll just do it
at the end kind of way but that's really
bad it's actually more expensive it's
more slow because you're going to get an
audit by one of us um CU all these
people here are you know very good firms
um and we're going to tell you like hey
your design does not work you're going
to have to rewrite this entire component
come back into months after you've
Rewritten it so before you thought you
were going to launch in December and now
you're launching in March so it's like
tax planning it's like post Hawk tax
planning doesn't work I equated it to
like the job of Homeland Security right
like the best job you do to the left of
the audit is never going to be talked
about but it's the highest Roi and the
highest uh the most difficult to
calculate um avoiding those those
situations so work you do initially is
also relevant to Security even if it's
not security oriented sometimes like
good design is something that makes
security assessment much easier even if
you have been thinking about security
the whole time then so I would
say being good at software development
helps Security in general yes y that
that dtail is nicely into another
question I want to ask the the panel
here and then maybe we'll have time for
a question or two from the audience if
uh they have some which is you know
talking to some folks here today who are
developers early in their projects
sometime some of them being first or
second time through this process what's
the the best piece of security advice
you can give them at the earliest stage
of their journey of creating something
new yeah oh sorry Michael did you want
to go go for um yeah like figure out
what you want your protocol to do and
what you want it to not do and write
them down and then like look at them
while you developing your code and then
add test for them add assertions for
them like we find this to be a very
common problem in our audits is that we
talk to the customer like okay so like
what are you worried about and they're
like well you know we don't want to get
hacked I'm like okay what does that mean
right you should know what it means for
your protocol to get get hacked so then
you can like actually think about like
okay well I'm worried about this or that
basically having a real threat
model I I'll add to that like definitely
100% thr modeling is like where you
should start um I I think because the
other thing is like people like security
has to scale with the project like are
you going to be able to afford to have
like a full monitoring infrastructure
set up like going to deployment if
you're like you know you don't have any
tvl you don't have a lot of things like
we will still say like yeah you should
probably do that but if you like
literally can't don't have the resources
like um a lot of teams I think will
because they start out without like a
lot of the security infrastructure or
support uh but then like suddenly in a
couple of months their tvls like grown
it's gotten massive there's a lot of lot
more value at stake they never really
thought through how are we going to like
upscale our security like I've seen
people that will build up their access
control and hardcode in something like a
ea owner and they're like well maybe we
should transfer it to a multis now and
they're like actually we don't know how
to do that we didn't prepare for it
that's like a a particularly egregious
example that does exist in a doll
protocol try looking for it um where
someone just hardcoded the owner and you
just hope that whoever has that key uh
never gets like kidnapped or decides to
go Rogue um so like but just in general
be prepared to like scale up your
security as you have the resources to
spend on it um and just even if you
can't spend on it today plan to know
like okay at some point at like this
level of tvl let's start like taking
whatever profits might come from that
and like invest it in uh making our
protocol more secure because like most
of yall here unless you're got unless
you win enough from this competition to
pay for for a whole audit um you know
you can't get your code audited from a
top tier firm but maybe at some point
you do or want to and and and yeah be
prepared to upgrade and other things
yeah like you want to have Escape
hatches for yourself it's kind of like
lawyering stuff up like have you anyone
here work with lawyers before they're
like so expensive it's like so annoying
so you tell them like okay okay we don't
need like this like freaking Cayman
Islands Panama thing just like make me
the Delaware LLC and just we'll fix it
later if it gets really big but you like
these things are you know lawyers are
good at like okay yeah we'll just like
move all this stuff over it'll be fine
they're good at like having these Escape
hatches for you because uh people have
been making legal contracts for a long
time think about your security and ways
so that you have Escape hatches for okay
now my thing has scaled how I'm going to
keep this secure as it's growing but you
know you don't want to like be dumping
tons of money on making your protocol
super fancy secure Leon because you
probably don't need it yeah I would say
start really simple you might have a lot
of very good ideas but really make the
minimal protocol you can do and you will
save a lot of money on security on
audits reuse valid components that have
been audited previously and understand
how they work and uh the audit process
will be much simpler for everybody one
final thing that I'd like to add is um
probably what you're going to be
building 99% of the time it's not going
to be original like a lot of people have
built something which is similar and you
can look at what happened to that right
if it's a web three project
um you know so go back see what what
happened how it failed and make sure
that your design um at the very early
stages and also your requirements um are
such that this will not happen that's
obviously very hard but if you do it at
an early stage it's going to be much
cheaper excellent um any questions from
the audience any that we could squeeze
in one or two questions if people have
it
hi uh so I'm building a uh debit card
solution uh where I'm assuming that once
a transaction signed and went to the
network it will be successful because
the whole thing is standardized but on
the parallel I am running a consensus
model which will monitor those
transaction if those are successful or
not and if if it goes fails uh it will
trigger the system and act accordingly
so what things I should keep in mind
like what could be the security threat
uh which I could uh I could face or
yeah so just to understand you're trying
to build a system where someone signs a
transaction submits it uh it succeeds or
fails and this is just for like a normal
payment so what we are trying to do we
are providing the trans transaction time
to 4 to 5 seconds so once the
transaction is signed and sent to the
network we assume that that will be
successful but on the parallel we are
running a consensus model that will
monitor those transaction and build a
consensus and will act accordingly like
if it faed due to network congestion or
some some logic error or something so
what other things I should keep in mind
uh like what other uh like scenarios uh
of which transaction could fail or how
it it's hard to say exactly because I I
think there's there's a lot more I would
need to know about the system but uh
just off the top of my head I would
say uh there could be an instance where
like the way that you're like the node
that you're monitoring it from uh is
somehow down or like I guess be prepared
for whatever infrastructure relying on
to be able to confirm success or failure
uh you have like General assumptions
here uh like we we are using blockless
protocol
which have different nodes and uh I
think those node transaction is failed
or successful so I think that that
wouldn't be the case but there could be
something uh of which I should be a
aware
about again I'm trying to second guess
of about how your system works but one
of the things that comes up is whether
the consensus algorithm has a finality
Gadget whether you can actually tell
whether a transaction has been finalized
or not or not cuz otherwise you'd need
to wait a lot more time than 4 seconds 4
seconds does sound really really low
though thank you time one more question
if anyone in the audience has
one one question over to the left
there hi uh so I'm not a security
resister myself but uh I've seen a lot
of hacks that are uh due to con sens
mechanisms and sometimes Mass Social
Engineering of a protocol I was
wondering what do you think about uh how
we can basically build uh mechanisms
that are more hardcoded to prevent such
uh
exploits more hardcoded though yeah
because uh basically the human factor is
more unpredictable how can we hard code
consensus to be less maybe it's a
difficult question when you say
consensus do you mean like like for
example a multi does that count as
consensus yes and also at scale like for
a DA for a da um yeah so transparency is
very important here because it makes it
a lot easier to see what you're actually
voting for for example I think one
notable example was there was one for um
tornado cach where they just like
proposed a thing and they're like yeah
it totally does this and it just like
did something else so yeah like
monitoring your dowo is pretty good
transparency another thing is just time
lock
So like um make it so it's easy to
cancel a thing that's in the pending
state in the time lock so this way
there's a longer window for like for
things that are like potentially
breaking to get canceled and noticed of
course the downside there is you get a
lot more latency so if you have some
critical thing that needs to get jammed
through uh it may make it hard to do
that timely so that's another trade-off
do you guys have any ideas yeah I I've
actually we we had some really fun
experience and I say fun in a sarcastic
way with Dows that were under some form
of governance attack um in one case like
a whale buying a lot of tokens and
trying to push through a proposal on
compound that would have given them even
larger part of the treasury and then
control the Dow and it the way they did
it was very tricky they took a bunch of
tokens they had purchased they spreaded
amongst Rec counts it we did actually
have security monitoring that picked
this up as strange activity um but even
then it's like okay so who is like a new
a genuine new delegate and who's one of
who's like uh you know one of these many
accounts controlled by this one entity
um there's very few ways to do that in a
permissionless system because you know
it's essentially a civil attack in that
sense as long as they have the resources
to allocate um I I think at least being
aware I think ultimately like having
reputation in the ecosystem and then
having some checks and balances on them
um and Recovery mechanisms like in that
case like having a multisig that can
veto proposals if they're somehow
violating the Dow but you have very
specific rules that multisig is elected
by the Dow they're
accountable that's where I'm starting to
go towards especially for Dows uh and
for multi themselves uh I think
definitely having strong reputation
possibly even kyc kind of depends people
are you know controversial around that
but I think if you can if everyone's if
it's appropriate to like say we know
these are individual people do a signing
ceremony where they're all in different
places and they can verify they're all
different people it's not like one guy
controlling four or five different Keys
um yeah I think it's like there's no
good technical solution to these things
these are just like okay having strong
social de mechanisms to recognize who's
a good actor and who's not cuz it it's
not as easy as like a etherum where it's
like okay running a bunch of nodes that
are all coming to determine as cancers
and the general idea is just like make
sure you have enough noes that they can
always outvote the bad notes on the
determinist of answer with multisig and
Dows these are not determin these are
not deterministic answers of like yes
this is good yes this is bad so there
does have to be a lot more work on the
consensus of who are the actors why are
they allowed to participate in the
system and how do you root out Bad
actors and prevent them from Gaining
control as a as a post you could
take the maker d approach and you could
make the decisions deterministic by
offloading it to
AI all right end of post all right
uh it's also an interesting experiment
anyways I'm curious how it goes so
another mechanism I've seen is to make
the Quorum of a governance mechanism
increase in size the more contentious
the vote is so that a simple majority is
not enough um so it's a variable
Quorum yeah of course it's like a
tradeoff between like how easy it is to
get stuff done same with time locks and
how safe it is yeah I mean on one end of
the spectrum it's just everything is
hardcoded on the other end of the
spectrum is just
like whatever goes
yeah any other final comments from the
uh from the panel here today and I know
we're a little bit over time but I want
to thank you all for for joining for
anyone in the audience who hasn't had an
opportunity to work with either immuni
or any of these firms these are some of
our favorites in the industry um there
are there are many others that are great
too but
to put together a panel uh with this
group because it's really great uh can't
can't go wrong with anyone sitting up
here um so uh anything any last words
panel I think everyone in this panel is
really
awesome
likewise I agree very nice VI thank you
all for joining us really appreciate it
and uh and hope everyone has a great
rest of the week um and with that I can
let the the panel go and I think we owe
some some rewards to uh to our TF
participants today thank you all
[Applause]
again
us e
[Music]
close out the day we have here full CTF
participants we're going to go ahead and
start with slipper
again with
set I'm going to I'll let slipper show
yeah all right so in addition to your
cash rewards again make sure that you've
given your wallet information your
correct Wallet information double triple
check it so you get your correct payment
um but if slipper is still here we do
have a physical gift for you if you want
to come up and grab it slipper you still
here
where come on up real
quick so in addition to the cash
congratulations again on being the first
one maybe you can show the rest of the
participants what we'll be giving out
here um to the finalists so in addition
to the cash prize we've got a nice uh
set of Beats by Dre Studio Pro
headphones for everybody to take home
and make sure you get your immuni swag
bag as well uh commemorating the event
here
today um let me go through and call
names up to come get your
stuff uh you to do in order
yeah it's
fine it's all right don't worry about
I'll just go all right so I'm going to
go in a I'm GNA go in a random order now
just because my spreadsheets a little
screwy
um oh perfect um wait no something's
wrong I can bring it to you
Billy by you
today chain security also left a little
bit of Swag here too so feel free to
grab something
there all right uh next we have
Tony Tony come on up congratulations to
you way to be a a finalist here in the
CTF lot of hours spent here today heads
down
you next we're looking for uh
NAA I'm I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly
pronunciation all right we'll hold that
one off to the
side is
is but are you sure that's a yeah this
is from Mixie
no no no thank
you you all right
Harry
Harry all
[Applause]
right congrats great work today good
work great
[Applause]
work J going by the name of just J
J the email is rkss k e k and some
numbers oh you got one okay so that's
okay it's all the same it's
fine yeah it's all good yeah just you
could just yeah it's all this same we
can just pass them
out great all right
perfect rage next
rage rage I love the
hat good
work all right there we go already
new just need a bag congratulations
great work great work
thank you thank
you Mage intern Mage inter great
work congratulations
Mage M4
K2
congratulations y Vlad
Vlad are you still here all right
Vlad Vlad I think you even won your
group too I believe so
congratulations neun
neun great work the early leader stays
on the leader
board and Valera last but not least
Valera congratulations great work great
work
uh once again thanks everybody for
coming through thanks for participating
in the CTF I know it's a lot of hard
focused work in one room all day um
please uh look forward to the $1.5
million ethereum protocol ATT tathan
that will be hosted soon um and with uh
the sponsors for that program and again
big thanks to the ethereum foundation
for uh for allowing us to run this event
here at Devcon and the friendly malt
citizens
Okami are you still here
Okami right thank you again take care
have a great rest of your week and enjoy
the rest of Devcon
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]